mais d'abord l'actualité Florent et
cette conséquence de l'attentat d'aras
le gouvernement veut accélérer
l'expulsion de 193 étrangers radicalisés
en situation irrégulière et combien sont
sous la menace en andrloir trop tôt pour
le dire expliquait hier le préfet à
notre micro le temps de passer au
Peigneux fin le fichier des personnes
radicalisées quelques dizaines
d'individus en indrloir certains
dangereux qu'el pourrait être leur
profil Clémence Dosque nous en dit
plus 183 c'est le nombre d'individus
inscrits au fichier des personnes
radicalisées en France et le
gouvernement presse les préfets à passer
cette liste au peignef dans chaque
département le préfet Patrice Latron
annoncé présider un groupe d'évaluation
départementale en ce sens avec la
procureur de la République certains
individus fich s pourrai faire l'objet
d'une obligation de quitter le
territoire l'objectif c'est d'arriver à
pouvoir rendre des décisions
d'obligation de quitter le territoire
français à garde de personne mais bien
entendu il faut réunir un faisceau
d'indice c'est tout le problème c'est
que le droit français fait de telle
sorte qu'on peut pas arrêter
préventivement des gens il faut qu'il y
ait un commencement d'exécution à minima
une préparation d'attentat par
exemple en septembre dernier trois
jeunes mineurs âgés de 15 à 16 ans ont
été mises en examen par un juge
antiterroriste parisien et ils ont été
arrêtés à jouer les tours jeunes
vulnérables et ou isolé le profil des
radicalisés reste complexe à définir
selon l'avocat Aben benjador les profils
ils sont extrêmement hétéroclites ce
qu'on a découvert c'est
que le l'engagement religieux la
radicalisation religieuse elle est pas
toujours synonyme euh de violence et
d'actes terrorisme et d'ailleurs ceux
qui provoquent des actes terroristes qui
s'en rendent complices ou qui en sont
d'ailleurs les commanditaires parfois ne
sont pas toujours des personnes qui ont
une pratique euh religieuse trrict il y
a un distingo à faire
inévitablement face à la menace
terroriste des militaires de l'opération
sentinelle seront déployés en Touren
dans les jours à venir ces événements
font écho à l'examen de la loi
immigration qui arrivera au Sénat en
novembre
prochain